sean ahí ve dos puntos distintos sobre
la parábola de cuadrada igual a 4x si el
eje de la parábola toca tangencialmente
a un círculo de radio r que además donde
el segmento ave es un diámetro ok con el
segmento ave como su diámetro entonces
la pendiente de la línea que une a yahvé
puede ser
y aquí nos dan estas cuatro opciones
entonces para poder resolver este
problema lo más fácil y lo más
conveniente es ver un dibujo así que
vamos a dibujar los ejes pues vamos a
hacer un poquito más derecho vamos a
intentarlo ok creo que no
y están un eje muy bueno solo más
derechito que podía hacer
y vamos a dibujar otro
creo que hoy estoy teniendo problemas
con los ejes ahí tienen otro eje
entonces este es el eje x este es el eje
y ok y bueno vamos a dibujar esta
parábola tenemos la parábola ye cuadrada
igual a 4x entonces esa es una parábola
que tiene vértice en el origen verdad
simétrica con respecto al eje x
y que abre hacia la derecha
nuestra parábola y esta es la parábola
de cuadrada igual a 4x muy bien ahora
bien si en realidad podemos sacar raíz
cuadrada tenemos dos ramas de esta
parábola la principal es de igual y si
sacamos la raíz cuadrada del lado
derecho tenemos raíz de cuatro que es 2
por la raíz de equis y acá tenemos abajo
es exactamente igual pero con un signo
menos verdad menos 2 raíz de x muy bien
ahora nos dicen que tomemos dos puntos
sobre la tabla sobre la parábola vamos a
tomarnos dos puntos digamos este punto
aquí tenemos un punto y un punto b y nos
dicen que este no si trazamos un círculo
resulta que el eje el eje bueno el eje
de la parábola que en este caso coincide
con nuestro eje x verdad este es nuestro
eje de la parábola coincide con el eje x
y que toca tangencialmente a un círculo
cuyo diámetro es ave oops
está un poquito mejor
y ésta
muy bien y este es nuestro círculo por
supuesto no es un dibujo perfecto pero
más o menos entiende verdad que este es
su diámetro ese es un diámetro de hecho
o que este dibujo no me gustó mucho
vamos a intentarlo hacer de nuevo
mucho mejor y cerramos el círculo
es bastante complicado
quizás es más complicado que resolver el
problema entonces tenemos ahora sí ya
este círculo cuyo diámetro está dado por
los puntos a ivey que se encuentran en
la parábola ok y aquí es tangencial en
un punto solo lo toque en un punto muy
bien entonces este como en su diámetro
entonces la longitud entre a y b es dos
veces r verdad donde re es el radio
entonces vamos a calcular la pendiente
de la línea que une aa llave y para
lograr eso lo que primero tenemos que
hacer es calcular o bueno ver cómo son a
y b
entonces por ejemplo
ahí ve
ahí ves son dos puntos que se encuentran
en la parábola digamos que si x si
nuestra coordenada x fuera cuadrada
entonces si si x es un a cuadrada
entonces ya es dos veces raíz de a que
es 2a verdad entonces aquí estamos
diciendo que nuestro punto a está arriba
y se expresa de la siguiente forma
también b lo podríamos decir bueno qué
tal si la coordenada x es un d cuadrada
entonces si b cuadrada es si x es de
cuadrada tenemos que dos veces la raíz
de b cuadrada es 2 b2b entonces cómo
calcular y amos el radio de este círculo
bueno esencialmente si nosotros nos
fijamos en el punto medio entre a y b ok
de este de este segmento que es el
diámetro de la circunferencia ok si nos
fijamos en este segmento que es el
diámetro de la circunferencia el punto
medio es el el centro de la
circunferencia entonces vamos a
calcular digamos el punto medio el punto
medio de entre a y b
digamos vamos a denotar lo así y esto
simplemente es sumar las coordenadas y
dividirlas entre dos verdad entonces la
primera coordenada va a ser a cuadrada
más be cuadrada sobre sobre dos coma y
sumamos estas coordenadas que es 2 a más
2 b entre 2 y de hecho esto este 2 los
dos los podemos cancelar aquí verdad y
aquí me queda a más b sería a más ve muy
bien entonces vamos a hacer un pequeño
dibujo para darnos cuenta este punto
este punto de aquí tiene la distancia al
círculo que es digamos en cualquier
punto es r en particular en la distancia
digamos vertical hacia abajo esto mide r
eso quiere decir que esta altura de de
aquí que estoy marcando es
muy bien pero también sabemos qué es lo
que sabemos vamos a ver
también sabemos que la altura de este de
este centro es de entonces a más ve
tienen que ser r y eso nos va a servir
muchísimo aquí está la altura la altura
es a más b y también dijimos que la
altura es r y eso nos va a servir
muchísimo porque nuestras respuestas
están dadas en términos de de reino de
a&b así que lo que tenemos que hacer
ahora es calcular la pendiente y eso lo
vamos a utilizar que además bcr muy bien
y ahora calculamos la pendiente la
pendiente como ya sabemos es simplemente
la elevación entre lo que avanzamos en
la dirección horizontal verdad entonces
la elevación digamos si éste ve aquí
tenemos aquí tenemos ave que es be
cuadrada como 2 b y aquí tenemos a que
es a cuadrada con más 2
verdad y este punto morado de aquí es
cuadrada más be cuadrada sobre 2 coma
además ve ahí están las coordenadas
entonces calculamos la pendiente entre a
y b calculando la pendiente entre a y b
decimos lo que avanza bueno la
diferencia que hay en la coordenada y
que es en este caso es 2 b - bueno vamos
a hacerlo al revés vamos a restar este
menos este que es 2 a menos 2 b entre la
diferencia de las coordenadas en x que
es cuadrada menos b cuadrada
- ve cuadrada vamos a simplificar esto
porque es dos veces a menos b y abajo
tenemos una diferencia de cuadrados así
que esto es a más b por a menos b y como
a y b son distintos podemos cancelar muy
bien estos y esto nos queda 2 entre a
más b y concluimos porque además b es r
entonces esto simplemente es 2 sobre r
entonces ya podemos estar muy tentados a
circular nuestra respuesta hace nuestra
respuesta a c pero hay que tomar en
cuenta algo implícitamente en este vídeo
en este en este ejercicio en este dibujo
yo considere ahí ve arriba de la
parábola verdad pude haber considerado
por ejemplo que a estuviera aquí y que
estuviera acá entonces tendríamos
esencialmente el mismo dibujo verdad el
mismo dibujo pero abajo
más o menos ahí está
circunferencia y el detalle aquí es que
la pendiente de esta línea que ahora
conecta este diámetro pues es es la
misma que teníamos arriba pero con signo
negativo verdad en vez de subir ahora
baja entonces una respuesta posible
también podría ser de de hecho este
problema es de varias respuestas
correctas y pues de entrada por ejemplo
si supieras que hay dos opciones
correctas entonces por este por estos
dibujitos que hicimos tenemos que ver
que una pendiente es menos la otra
verdad entonces de entrada uno podría
decir ah bueno pues tengo que elegir a
ive o por otro lado tengo que elegir la
idea entonces en ese sentido tendríamos
un 50 por ciento de probabilidad de
adivinar pero no queríamos adivinar
realmente queríamos resolver el problema
y eso fue lo que hicimos espero que lo
hayas disfrutado